the organizers for inviting me here and
thank you for coming to the top this
talk is said said I booster population
on random graphs in particular I will
focus on the population any random graph
this is based on George world with how
much much higher a post-op of my nephew
glad so what is a booster population
work stripper collision on a graph given
a graph and we also given a so-called
infection threshold r which is a natural
number and what we do is that we start
from a so called a set of initially
infected vertices so we know that there
is a set of initially infected vertices
and then in each step every uninfected
uninfected vertices becomes infected if
it has at least are infecting neighbors
kind of a determinist process said NHS
type we in fact everything if it has our
infecting neighbors and once it is these
a vertex become infected it becomes
infected forever this poster
populational graph has been introduced
long time ago on Betty lattice perhaps
the physicists know better but electives
in the context of this older system but
I want to talk about it because I don't
know much about it but then the
dependency between the final set of
infected vertices on the federal clip
the size of the server initially
infected vertices as it has been studied
a lot so how big should be the initially
infected vertex L so that perhaps almost
all the vertices become infected in the
end or maybe only a small number of
additional vertices might be infected it
can be honest
the initial initially infected don't
accept and this has been studied a lot
on infinite trees finite create it also
random graphs such as random regular
graphs we have seen a lot of nice
results on the random regular graphs in
this conference and also the end of
shredding random graph GNP order
so-called binomial random graph GNP as
well as in homogeneous random brofist
sometimes we call here in this community
stochastic models in a very very general
setting that in this talk I will focus
on the Mediterranean graph setting and
G&P as I said we have a freedom of the
infection threshold so let's say R
equals 1 what happens to just to do a
sanity check when r equals 1 it's kind
of simple given our every vertex if it
has at least one infected neighbor it
will become infected because the
infection thread show this one as a
result a component containing as any
component containing at least one
infected vertex will become eventually
infected what does that mean is that any
component containing containing at least
one infected vertex will eventually
affect it well is it to analyze
therefore from now on our focus on the
case when they are the infection
threshold is in this tomb in the
throughout the talk I will denote by a
the initial the set of initially
infected vertices of tu sais c'est à and
which will be chosen uniformly at random
among all the set of vertices of given
size a4 caused by symmetry we can take
any deterministic set of dead sighs so
with the loss of your terrible assume
that a that initially infected set will
be a set of integers 1 through a and a
of f iOS of F will we will denote the
final set of infected
vertices as i said the lot of study has
been made between the relation or the
behavior of the final set or the size of
the final set versus the size of the
initial set so and still like this
conference is about phase transition so
nature question is is there of size of
transition in terms of bed or more is
there any threshold phenomena if so what
is the critical value and if so then
what is the width of the critical window
this kind of things has been studied
among others by Johnson you chop trova
and valya so there are other works but I
will just focus on this one as I would
like to talk more another thing that
they have shown indeed this is dramatic
simplification of their wonderful work
more than 50 pages of the paper i just
put on this one slide and it some other
things what they show is the following
we say we fixed our infection threshold
we fix the size of the infection
initially infected said what we can vary
in this world is the probability
distribution so h probability P if the
edge probability P is at least n to the
minus so 1 over N much much issues it's
not it it's not fixed you will also be a
perimeter so what you can imagine the
fixed are our fixed p satisfying this
range I fix p so I did I there are two
models did you ask question correctly
and because i was messing what they need
so they can be tomorrow's when you want
to change something you can fix r & P
and change the size of a or you check
your fix r and p no no sorry hey and
change the feet i want to talk about the
model where I will fix feet and change a
get there are two waters but I think I
messed up you have to thank you so now
fixed fixed fee so defined this 1 over L
it's much much louder well larger than 1
over N but much much smaller than and to
the power of minus 1 over R give it any
such p what we can show is
with high probability there is a
threshold a critical such that if the
size of an initial infected set is
smaller than a critical then only a few
additional vertices are infected and
just begin reading the session although
as I said it's much more small on the
other hand if the size of the initially
infected said is larger than AC a
critical then with high probability
almost every vertex becomes infected in
the sense that that's final set is the
abode l- lick you all over em and as I
said I overly simplified the result
indeed we do know the explicit formula
for the a critical the critical size of
the initial in fact itself as well as
the width with will be the square root
of the critical value so we know almost
everything but as I said the results
hold with high probability on the other
day I didn't write here the result it's
not that because it's it's pouring the
pic because it tests it does have a
different behavior and and kind of
simpler so light PR is now at least two
and for example when p is equal to a big
o of n to the minus one we know that the
GNP consist of either only of small
components if the p is much smaller than
1 over N or if it said every degree is
bounded let's say D then we do have a
giant component and a lot of small
components so still what is clear is
that in this regime we do have lots of
small components so in order to integral
most every vertex it's clear that we
have to in fact we have to start with
the verses which are infected and lies
on each of these similar components
so like in this picture in order to
interact almost everything in this
Reggie as I said because it consists of
so many small components we have to
start with almost every vertex infected
everything in that component of course
when P is P if the graph has average
degree cousin every degree it's really
to be more sophisticated but never
leaves you you should you can show that
in order to have a almost every vertex
being infected you have to start with
almost every vertex infected initially
so in this area because we had a to kind
of a constraints and now in this region
why this regime is kind of separate
let's say in this regime of and to the
minus one over R look at it so say this
is a set of an infected varices look at
a vertex and check whether there are at
least are infected neighbors of course
we can easily checked the number of
number of infected neighbors number of
vertices expected number of races sorry
with at least are impacted neighbors
infecting neighbors we can compute
easily you can compute it easily because
this sort of binomial coefficient this
is roughly and times so i have n minus
infected vertices if we are in the
initials case then it's almost n times P
to the are but on the other we are in
this regime so this is just constant so
we have a constant number of expected
number of vertices which has analysts
are impacting neighbors with constant
probability maybe we'll be in fact such
vertices on the other one can show that
indeed if you start with the initial set
of infected vertices of constant size if
this constant is and this are then we'll
post the probability there will be a 0
small population meaning almost every
vertex becomes connected it's kind of
rather easier consequence and if you're
looking into it in this regime if the P
is much much larger than n to the minus
one over R now this quantity becomes
infinity on the other you can also show
using other method that indeed also any
initial set of constant size eventually
spread to the entire set with high
probability so there is interesting
regime here as well but as I said I will
focus on this regime we want to improve
this part as I said much of the results
are known as i will show you in the next
slide but our target is to show this
that with a high probability but
exponentially high probability one of
the motivation was because Valley asked
us to do that in some conference because
we had other results and then he asked
us whether we can do this also for GMP
and we worked a little bit and played a
little bit in linear spy surprising
surprisingly there were very elementary
mathematics to show this so Oh from now
on the formulas mayhew complicated
mathematics behind will be very
elementary so now if fix our is at least
two p as i said the most interesting
regime please much much larger than n to
the minus one and much much is smaller
than n to the minus one over R now i
will show you many technically looking
fun to tease but i will explain later
hopefully we'll be able to explain how
these quantities appear naturally the
first thing will be our kind of time t0
little bit also why this time is this
quantity 1 plus delta which will
influence the kind of a failure
probability later times 1 minus R
factorial divided by n times odd power
of P to the 1 over R minus one hour I
promise that I will show you why this
quantities appear here Delta we want to
wish to make it as small as possible
because it will be influencing the
exponential failure bound but the way we
we make our proof so elegant
show proof we had to use the result on
giant component in order to apply that
particular technique we had some
restriction taking a restriction the
deltas should be larger then n times P
to they are because of the restriction
we know that this concept k tends to 0
but then we raised to the power 1 over 2
times r minus 1 and it should be larger
than n times P now n times P is a
growing number so I put some negative
power minus 1 over 4 times i minus 1 as
I said due to the condition on P this
Delta is nevertheless little one as I
say we want to make it as small as
possible but this is what we can do then
there are two other quantities there are
more essential to define it we leave the
probability that binomial distribution
with parameters T and P is at least our
which I denoted by PI of tea then I was
telling this a critical the critical
value for this transition in terms of
the size of the final set is this
quantity sub-minimum minus minimum of n
times pi of t minus T divided by 1 minus
x of t know why did appear naturally you
receive it later as I said I promise
which if you compute it is approximately
of this number see this contact is
appearing there and here is what's all
the same and T critical is the smallest
TT wear this in this minimum is reached
if you compute it will see that this
quantity appears everywhere as I said
but this level of this is much much
smaller than p2 minus 1 as I said
hopefully I will be able to show you why
this quantities of you naturally but if
we work on some so-called article
problem the maximal sub graph of a graph
whose minimum degrees and lists are you
will see that not exactly this formula
but something similar formula might
appear so when you analyze this one you
might wonder whether this has to do we
our core of the final infection set but
I think there is a relation but up to
now that I cannot formulate it in a most
elegant way nevertheless to state the
theorem let Omega 0 be any function
which is much much larger than the
window size of the window the width of
the window namely square root of AC then
if the size of the initially infected
this initially infected set is equal to
acs a critical minus omega 0 if you want
to reread it of course you can read it
as as like set size of the set-
criticality normalized by double the
size of the window you can also read it
in this fashion then with high
probability i will read it later the
size of the final inspection set is it
is a most secret code as i said indeed
on the other hand we can show not only
with high probability with exponentially
high probability to be with one minus
one minus is missing sorry one bynars so
1 minus exports minus some constant
times square of the Omega 0 divided by t
0 so the reason why I did write in this
fashion is the answer no Chuck turbine
valia did is we want to quantify this
tale your problem you just write a
failure probably sorry for them 1 minus
X so to capture this failure probability
we had this is this speed of the
convergence and this influence this
failure probability and photo mobility 0
is also influencing our failure
probability on the other hand as you can
imagine the other way around when this
quantity tends to positive infinity then
what yunso net arshad is that with high
probability the size of the final set is
n minus little o of n so we improved it
by showing this exponential bound again
this quantity the constants are
different we have a
rather lengthy ugly fella very
displeased formula and again this
failure probability depends on this
omega 0 square of the omega 0 / 20 by
looking at it you might see why we plug
in this one so if we want to have a
better smaller failure probably we wish
to have Delta very small we'd be looking
at this is not optimal indeed you can do
better but as I said the proof is really
elegant using this powerful serum
bipolar version real down and therefore
we have this unwashed bound on that but
if you want to improve it maybe you can
have different approach so let me say a
few words about the proof how we shall
prove it yeah
so you're saying AC coincides with these
parameters mpr nothing exactly then arc
or not i'll call the GNP but I think I
core all the way if I have known if I'm
a god i don't i don't have a religion if
there is a god but then i will know the
final set of the infection final in fact
it's set then this will be the Alcor of
that one but of course we have a just a
baby we don't know the structure we just
don't know what we are just talking up
the size not even though structure why
I'm talking about it is that if i look
at this proof how it goes or how we
prove it it does make the so-called one
propagation thing that I have done with
our me go glam recently where is
catherine with cass fields cookie as
well it's a it is not exactly the same
but it kind of gives me a feeling that
it has to do with it but the problem is
that i don't know the fine structure of
the fire set but i can correlate with
very nice Carlton Watson tree not with
the average DVD but I have to construct
it so it has some loose connection but I
don't know the connection that's the
annoying part
possible no as I said it's the proof
Elton Cicero's one yeah why does it
matter what the deltas that is kind of
awesome fix the number i can also say
that it equal but i can also make it as
small as possible if i wish if i can
prove it but as i said one part indeed
the most elegant part of the proof uses
a giant component i have to put the
thing in the weekly supercritical regime
this is just a concussion and look at
this one this is on the bottom the
smaller t0 is the better I wish to make
data to be 0 Delta can be 0 if if data
is 0 then I will be completely happy
because they match to my tea critical
time where the threshold appears now
will be buried but I have to go a little
bit further this TC is indeed in the the
lower bound of the infected cell at time
T C at time t see the number of vertices
that I infected will be at least TC TC
but any time T i will show you I indeed
in the profits hidden any time TT I
haven't talked about this time but each
step I was talking about each step there
is it a step whatever the step was and
you will see that as I said if t0 was
not t0 but TC you see from this one bit
we went a little bit further so that we
have a sharper concentration so my
wishes reef delta is 0 I will be very
happy we can discuss mate
not about the connection with the
operation well regular danza is an exact
duality between boost our calculation
and the dynamics of the reduction to the
art form not to the app got the degree
minus airport yeah you are another gym
while the degrees are very much
concentrated yeah so if you want
proximities by i mean if you are
proximately and be by owned by a regular
graph telegraph with the Infinity degree
infinity sons in yeah oh yeah good times
it yeah and and then it's quite natural
was the connection like that on the
other hand if the degree is unbounded
the scars of what I would say is that
there is a very elegant approach to the
cake or problem through the garden
wasn't tree with multi type garden
wasn't indeed it's not single type of
multi type to remember where the
vertices in the coup or not so well it
really needs a kind of beautiful thing I
want you to apply it but the point is
that there we have to use this local
structure namely the GNP with the
boundary degree can be approximated by
the garden wasn't tree but if you are
degrees unbounded it's not any more
trouble Isabel correlations with things
so I don't know whether there will be
this elegant be super elegant a
multi-time captain wasn't true
absolutely but Adam is why think
mentioning it so yeah I'm not saying
that it was a way to prove it but to
wait save that it was quite natural that
yeah yeah exactly so if you you can work
on the Skakel things if you look at this
you will see oh yeah oh my god this is
this this function that is appearing all
the time yeah not only conceptually but
also quantitatively analytically if you
see this function it's kind of a bummer
there should be connection and as you
said you lose connection what this is
about all this technical statement as I
said I just highlight is proofing the
reason being that if something is
watching this video so that he doesn't
complain so the almost of the
which is written as black is almost the
same as the answer no chapter of eval
yet except that they don't use the
binomial but they use the puzzle of
course we know the person and binomial
are very close relatives but it's some
if you look at the windows inside but
sometimes it makes keepers but in this
particular case it doesn't make any
difference so we chained twisted little
bit but that's important they are the
same and also instead of this one minus
exponential probably they have just with
high probability with additive error
terms so the rest of the talk I want to
give you some ideas about the proof as i
already said several times that it's
really short and elegant proof or
elementary proof we will use the
reformulation due to scallion tomba and
then we will set up some martingale so
that we can have the number of infected
vertices is concentrated around its mean
with exponentially high probability in
the early stage of the process it's true
at the early stage of the process and in
the sub kraker case because the number
of infected vertices will be small
enough so can just imply we can apply
this martingale concentration result
through the sub critical case on the
other hand for the super critical case I
have a lot of typos indeed so I was
changing this morning and so indeed I
flame his talk to be a blackboard talk
and I realized there is no blackboard
and there is a white port and then there
was no shifting up and downs I decide to
make it quick so sorry for this all this
type of stuff anyway it's the early
morning the brain thing in the
supercritical regime because we want to
go further the martingale concentration
is not strong enough the reason is that
in the super critical case we already in
fact at least t0 vertices whatever the
number was and then because then the
probability where the martingale is
sufficiently concentrated decreases
dramatically once we reach there's 20
infected numbers so we have to do
something more on
we have infected enough number of
vertices then comes this elegant thing
what is it is that sub graph spanned by
vertices with exactly r minus 1 impacted
neighbors close so that it contains the
largest component our largest component
it's not yet linear size but kind of a
pitch low minus one size once a vertex
in this giant component is infected
every vertex in the giant component will
be infected as I said the size of the
giant is not yet linear but on the other
you can just make the other vertices
infected quickly using Chernov so that's
my plan so how it works as i said i
promise that i will do some
reformulation it looks very technical
there for our use just to play a
whiteboard what is written you don't
need to read it we will examine the
infected vertices one by one and
determine the vertices that has exactly
our neighbors in the previously exam in
the vertices this is written every
little pies n of T to be the set of D
examine the vertices I of T be the
number of vertices there are infected so
what is it as I said forget about it so
given a time T we have a set settee
is that t minus one to describe 0t i
will do this in each step and if if
there are interested vertices that has
not been not yet been examined as i said
a set of vertices that are infected our
delivered by empty infected vortices at
time t minus one and set the number of
vertices set of vertices that are
examined almond impacted processes if
there is a additional vertex which
doesn't allow z t minus one but lies in
t minus ones that are infected but not
yet examined let's call it beauty you
can select it in arbitrary manner as you
wish you'd select one vertex in the
difference and you included in your set
and you call this new set as Z of T so
that set of vertices that are examined
what you do then and outside the world
there are not initially infected it
doesn't matter whether they are infected
or not but I ignore them i just look at
all the vertices that will not infected
in missionary all the viruses up to n
minus a so this is just m and check
whether it has r minus one infected
neighbors by doing caracas enlist our
neighbors in the examined vertices not
in fact it's indeed impacted but examine
the vertices so what I have done here is
the I want to associate this continent
with some indicator random variable I
put one if the vertex AI plus eight plus
I has and these are neighbors
in that tea the exam in the vertices
otherwise a zero then I'm ready to
define I of T so a of T the set of the
infected vertices that time T will just
be the union of them initially in fact
it said so initially infected said I
said ta so one through a union on the
vertices that has and lists our
neighbors in that this is what is
written here then it is easy to see that
set of teeth gizem in the vertices the
set of the exam in the vertices will be
the subset of strength the subset of the
a of teeth the infected a set that's how
we define it and we set the large t be
the minimum time T such that the
infective set is identical to the exam
in the set why because if there is no
vertices which is infected but not yet
examined I have no verte icici to
examine therefore the population stops
there there will be no further
infections once we reach that point this
is identical to the minimum T such that
the cardinality of a of t is equal to t
each time we examine one vertex so at
time T we will have we have examined all
the infected vertices in this is target
function and the final set of impacted
vertices will be identical to a of G so
this has been used also in the lands on
a toilet paper and i promise that i will
show you some some numbers where all
these strange computations all car
because it's kind of a very simple I
mean I may not do because time is
running out how much time do I have only
ten minutes he seems like it
yeah so I skip it why this all contact
disappearance is really cute just to
calculus but I just move on to the
martingale if you look at it if you look
at what's going on is that in each step
in worst case in a of T we might in fact
n minus IHT vertices in single step it
was the case of course what might happen
in the early stage of the process that
we are targeting for martingale a of T
is usually little off end so it was the
place we might just in fact in one step
and minus the claw of n vertices so if
you work on martingale concentration
inequalities of course words important
thing is the maximal one step difference
it is a linear you don't have any hope
to have a very sharp concentration so we
have to refine this multi game this is
how we do in this picture what is going
on is the following we distinguish the
vertices this hour read this part very
fatigued before defining this quantity
because it looks terribly completely but
it's not so this quantity was just the
same bed look at the vertex I plus a
plus I and check whether it has I at
least our neighbors in Z of T we will
refine this just looking one by one
vertices until a plus I we check it but
for vertex after that a plus i plus 1
now that's it's written here for the
vertex a plus i plus 1 on what we will
do is a goober check whether it has are
at least our neighbors in z t minus 1
this is very technical matter but it
helps us or not now we have this
quantity up to here we use this nice x
time TI but up to here from here on we
use because I minted sad in one step
below jay jay jay can run anything so
this is where it's written here where is
written here we set up some some random
variable MTI so this pair will define a
total ordering using the lexicographical
order so for any search which is non
zero so it is kind of trivial about the
condition we define the random variable
m to be the sum of random verbal XP j
where j runs from 1 through I and check
whether it has are at least our
neighbors in the t minus pie hat of T
this is almost a binomial except the
stopping time condition / 1 minus pi PI
head of t plus we check the rest of the
world for those J larger than a plus I
whether it has at least our neighbors in
the previous step set t minus 1 and you
do this then one thing that is easy is
that the cardinality of Aoki I just
really love from here it was Kadena
lucky is the size of the set a 0 it was
a plus indicator random variables yeah
from here on the other hand using this
quantity by taking the last one and
minus a this some disappears what is
left is here so you do there just a
little R it's Matty their first year
care plus even the high school students
can do that if you do this you obtain
this one why this is nice we understand
very well the binomial random variable
what it's stopped binomial random
variable but we understand it very well
it's highly concentrated and M this new
random variable if it does have nice
behavior than we are done he does have a
nice behavior indeed the sequence of
random variables m 0 n minus a through
the end from the marching gift just to
make sure I wrote down the definition of
marchantia but maybe in
community I don't need to explain it so
it does from a multi game and you can
use standard martingale inequality but
on the other hand there is a very nice
one due to Chung and Lou which extends
the result of the McDermott it's quite
well football purpose so when we use it
and we get the martingale concentration
for the sub critical case we are almost
done as I promised the reason is that if
you look at the a critical which was
defined I just rewrote the definition
using the T critical it's just the
quantity that i have written there and
also a of TC we know the number of
infected vertices at the critical time
we know and we do just a little
arithmetic then in the end we get that
the number of infected vertices on till
critical time is smaller than critical
time with exponentially high probability
that I said using the constant I hide
this constant but there was also other
term this kind of very technically
licking inequality indeed so sub clicker
case was quite easy now super critical
case it's indeed nice so I just use a
picture to prove it you do not need to
read it
as I said this is the kind of the father
I like most the martingale inequality in
the subcritical case is not yet enough
but nevertheless it does produce a huge
set of infected vertices of size as I
said at least the t0 plus omega 0 / 2
and i divide this set in two parts
namely my examined set of vertices it's
quite huge and little prison one for
later as I call it a one is it's too
lengthy and this potato size of the a
tourism is about omega 0 / 4 so this
part is a reservoir I keep it the what
we do is you look at the set of vertices
outside of that world and check whether
it has exactly all minus two neighbors i
minus 1 sorry neighbors in there and I
call it be head it's written there set
of vertices which has exactly iron mild
wasn't one neighbors in that examined
the vertices up to time T 0 plus Omega 0
/ 4 then it's not yet iid random verse
of the iron random verbal of that phone
but on the other hand the number of
vertices that has been many neighbors is
statically dominating some nice binomial
random variable therefore we can also
say the size of the set in a very nice
manner and indeed the size of this set
is 1 plus epsilon x to the minus 1
because epsilon is hiding all this dirty
constant or quantities depending on n
Omega 0 and Delta nevertheless if you
look closely how this debt epsilon is
defined or behaving we can show the
deceased in the so-called weekly
critical regime of the GNP
it does contain a giant component be of
size of their size so it does contain a
giant component size almost 2 epsilon
over 1 plus 2 epsilon P inverse what is
the good thing about instead we do not
have only with a high probability result
but also exponentially high probability
result due to with exponentially high
probability due to below passion Reardon
will appear this year hopefully he is
done they have done all the work that I
need thanks to devil though you are
trying to prove it and they were quicker
so due to other reasons it did they
wanted to apply this result to the local
limit theorem for the giant component
nevertheless so using this one we can
guarantee that with high probability
there is a giant component it's not yet
it's not yet big enough so what is one
can show is that once a single vertex
here is connect two connected to our
digital infected vertices then it has
exactly our neighbors that are infected
therefore this vertex will be infected
but since this vertex will yeah just pry
the infection through the whole
component this B will be completely
infected
so now we have a giant infected said
it's not yet enough as i said the size
is still not too far away from end n
which we are targeting for so what we
can do is we just kind of a repeat what
we know you check the set C but it has
are at least our neighbors will be
before I came here I gave a talk in
obama [ __ ] weeks ago at the time we'd
repeat this business there if some of
you are in the undertow so we just look
at r minus 1 neighbors here and we check
whether there is additional vertex here
but we don't need to do that indeed you
can just too honest check whether this
vertices outside these two has at least
our neighbors in be it does have with
exponentially high probability for the
war the size of this will be at least 30
minus 1 p minus 1 it's not yet close to
n so what can you do you're just wicked
check weather outside the world has at
least our neighbors in the infected set
yes does d the size of a GD is as we
wished and minus ility love and we can
show using the channel chatter mph
checker off and of course d is contained
in the final in fact is set and we are
done they said very simple proof for
rather complicated looking result thank
you very much for your attention